growing political fallout from alleged
terrorist plot to violently overthrow
the michigan state government
six men connected with a right-wing
group are charged with trying to carry
out an elaborate plan
to kidnap the democratic governor of
michigan
seven others are charged with providing
material support the group allegedly
wanted to try
governor gretchen whitmer for what they
call treason
or potentially kill her jeff begase is
in washington jeff
how did law enforcement stop this plot
well it took a lot of fbi resources that
is for sure it took
undercover operatives confidential
informants and dozens of recordings
investigators tell us this is a plot
that been been in the planning stages
since about
june the group even had a meeting
planned for this week
until the fbi moved in
according to an fbi affidavit the
alleged conspirators met in a room under
a trap door in a home
spent the summer training with firearms
and explosives
and tried to recruit 200 men to storm
the state capitol building and take
hostages
including governor whitmer who they plan
to try for treason
the alleged conspirators used
operational security measures
including communicating by encrypted
messaging platforms
and used code words and phrases
prosecutors say the group eventually
decided to kidnap whitmer at her
vacation home
even going so far as to conduct
surveillance there one of the alleged
ringleaders adam fox said that governor
whitmer has
uncontrolled power right now and
described the plan as a snatch and grab
another barry croft later stated all
good
things must come to an end governor
whitmer has faced significant pressure
from right-wing groups for her refusal
to lift strict coronavirus lockdowns
something that also made her a favorite
target of president trump who in april
tweeted
liberate michigan later that month two
of the suspects are seen
at the capitol with our militia groups
that have been storming the building to
fight pandemic restrictions
some of the suspects were also visible
online their social media accounts
riddled with anti-government and pro-gun
views these politicians
that keep robbing us and taking our
money but information gathered through
confidential informants is what
ultimately foiled their alleged plot
yesterday governor whitmer thanked law
enforcement for their efforts while also
pointing the blame at president trump
for what she says is legitimizing the
actions of extremist groups
the president of the united states stood
before the american people
and refused to condemn white
supremacists and hate groups
like these two michigan militia groups
the president responded last night
and you know i see whitmer today she's
complaining but it was our justice
department that arrested the people that
she was complaining about it was my
justice department that arrested them
the militia group identifies itself as
the wolverine
watchman not in the court papers is
whether president trump's statements or
actions influence the group in any way
if convicted on all these charges the
suspects face up to life behind bars
gail i'll take this one jeff thank you
very much all the more concerning now
just 20 odd days to election day itself